this was on Gawker I really don't know
much about Gawker to me Gawker sounds
like something that is like not I don't
know if it's legit journalism or what I
have no [__] idea but
uh this was a real interview get it
becomes normal this is a real interview
about a [__] toaster swing of it it
gets it becomes normal I mean you if
you've seen a haunted toaster right
let's stop it right there let's stop it
right there let's stop it right there
haunted toaster are never two words that
should go together
okay because toasters only do one thing
and that's make make bread hot they make
bread crispy that's what they do know
what they don't do possess you know what
they don't do go
o a toaster is one thing and that's a
toaster okay but let's keep going dude
let's keep listening guy looks like
Francis Ford Copa all good now there's a
[__] elbow of a chick let's see when
they zoom out what she looks like we
heard a qtip
her head is the top of a Q-tip or the
bottom of a Q-tip because if you turn a
Q-tip around it's the same [__] it's one
of those things like race car when you
take race car you flip all the letters
around it still spells race car or
toot this lady is basically the [__]
human equivalent of
toot
so uh why was this a hairdo by the way
in the [__] what was it the early 80s
why was this a hair do dude just that
one big poof just a big [__] poof it
looked like right before the atam bomb
got re where you really started to worry
you know like you'd see an explosion be
like wo that's big and then you're like
wait a second oh that's what her hair
was it just got that big before it
[__] mushroom
clouded um so yeah so that's what it
looks like let's find out her name her
name is going to be something I am the
devil it let's go a little bit back
because when you do a when you play
something and you st and you stop it and
then you talk about a little bit and
then you play it on a podcast and then
you don't realize you're at the part
where the lady said I am the devil you
got to go back you got to go back and
you got to say what the [__] she was
talking about am my bad for Talking
sometimes you know sometimes you know
what I mean that happens especially like
in relationships when I'm with Kristen a
lot of times we'll be talking and I'll
be saying something and then she'll talk
over me and then I'll be like oops right
because a sentence never ends in my and
that was the last word I said right so
if that was the last word I said my then
what happened then I guess maybe I got
cut off right and we shouldn't be doing
that should we and then she goes Chris
and I say okay so can I go back and she
says okay and then I guess what I forgot
what the [__] I was going to say yes
dude yes had to lay down the law in the
process of laying down the law he forgot
what he said which is fine because you
need to lay down the law a lot in a
relationship all good
but it's real love real love oh I'm
searching for a real love
someone whatever real
love just
[__] I could be in that
group I was six when it came out so uh
what did she say you heard I am the
devil they heard the what kind of voice
did the devil
have um a a very very low voice I'd say
sounded like Eli wallik wow dude the
toaster had a very low voice that
sounded like Eli
wallik the cool thing about this podcast
is when I wake up in the morning I never
know about the sentences that will be
coming out of my mouth later on in the
day and the one that shocked me so far
is that toaster had a low voice that
sounded like Eli wallik but I ended up
saying it if you had woke woke me up
this morning and said hey Chris guess
what you're guess what you're going to
either say or here today and I said what
and you
said the toaster had a low voice that
sounded like Eli wallik I would think
one thing it must be podcast
day it must be podcast day and it is
who's Eli wallik anyway I got to look
him up Eli I definitely heard the name
before wow imagine the toaster talk Eli
wallik when did he die 2014 wow he lived
long well he lived to be
99 what does he sound like let's see Eli
wallak
voice here we
go Eli wallak why he always plays the
bad guy okay so he played on toaster I
have a feeling that the first imprint
you make on fil that's not him as a
child I used to see these movies where
the was heating no are you at all
concerned that today people are a little
bit aware of what violence in films is
doing and here you are good Bad and the
Ugly as mean and vicious a performance
and a at a thesis as as could be iMagic
yes but you see when you say violence
this is how he sound I don't think
there's anything more violent than
what's happening in the world today yeah
okay but that's not the question is it
Eli W let's talk about well okay that's
what Eli wallak sounded like
dude maybe Subway the Metro it took 20
minutes this is what the to night after
I finished working I had my makeup on
I'm sitting in the subway not even that
evil hey toast is
done all right so let's go back to this
thing I got to [__] let's go back to
this thing here let's think let's see
what the [__] this lady's getting
at saved any of this satanic toast yes I
did save it because I wanted to be sure
that somebody else would see it now this
one can you see that Richard
say
the tust has an imprint that says Satan
lives just eat it dude it it says Satan
lives she did it hey Jun
O'Brien you did it hey you're trying to
trick us that Satan's in the toaster
also how about the ego you got to have
to think even if she was being serious
the ego you got to have to think my
toaster is haunted but it's not just a
demon Satan's at my
house that's
unreal to be like my house is the one
that Satan comes
to what about his you know what I mean
what are they called evil AR archangels
what about the [__] fallen angels
what about them huh your house is so
[__] dope with the with the with the
uh perrywinkle wallpaper Satan showed up
to that one you think Satan doesn't like
Comfort Satan is the [__] dude in the
Underworld Sorry God but you know what I
mean when I was a kid I used to say
swear words and [__] and then I would go
sorry God I'd look up in the air and I'd
say Sorry God as if God was up there
looking down at me like this oh send
[__] Satan down your
toaster dude that was
myd people somebody asked me the other
day when did you know you had OCD and I
said well it [__] for sure flared its
head when it was when I was in my early
20s and he said oh really and I said
yeah but there were always signs and he
was like like what and should have said
that whenever I said a swear word I
looked up and said sorry
God now that's just as ridiculous as is
thinking Satan's cooking your
sandwiches
but
however remember when you used to write
an essay in high school and you just it
it needed to be a certain amount of
words and you just every other sentence
was however so you'd be like [__]
that's 16 howevers I got [__] 16
words right
there I would do it and uh when I
exhaled my nose snot came out but then
it went back in it was like when Jeff
Bezos went to space he got up there a
little bit and then well okay cool and
then dipped out that's what my [__]
Boogie did this is clicking around um so
uh my my audio is clicking around yes
that's amazing so
um so yeah so Satan lives with this it's
just the ego people have to think that
like to for even for me as as a
six-year-old when I would say Sorry God
or even as an 11-year-old to say Sorry
God to [__] be like okay but that's
something an 11-year-old does but this
woman is a full-fledged adult saying Hey
to believe let's say she does believe
this and she's not trying to trick
people which I think she is trying to
trick people to think that we're not the
like we're such big idiots that we don't
think
that you do that you did that and tried
to trick us is one thing but to if we
say we you thought we believed you still
what about your [__] ego that Satan
is at your
house
also Satan lives that's how he's going
to say it in your toast you think Satan
can't pick up a [__] marker you think
Satan can't [__] find where your
lipstick is and write it on your mirror
he's gonna he's going to burn your bread
he's going to burn it in your bread dude
it's so annoying when people think that
ghosts and [__] are real I got a buddy
that literally was like I said to him I
was like do you believe in that [__] all
that paranormal [__] and he says oh 100%
And I was like why why and he said oh
dude I [__] cuz I know it does cuz it
cuz CU it happened to me once and I said
really something irrefutable and he was
like 100% and I said well what is it and
I said and dude keep it
short and he said okay I'll try I swear
to God it took an hour Christen he was
doing voice notes cuz I was like don't
text it's going to take too long he was
doing voice notes Kristen 45 minutes in
she was like what the [__] what are you
listening to it was him telling me how
one time he moved into an apartment in
[__] Los Angeles and like his his car
had a boot on it and then a tire was
missing and then like it looked like
there was burnt wallpaper and then hair
in his bathtub and he thought it was the
guy that used to live here that [__]
killed himself and I'm like that's not
irrefutable irrefutable evidence
man this [__] never happened to me
where's my toast where's my Satan toast
where's my lipstick on the mirror that
says watch out watch behind you where's
all that [__] where's the lights even
flickering dude it's always explainable
by electricity or
science lives just terrible is the
toaster still
possessed I I we're we still have
trouble off and on with it yes oh she's
cooking toast now here we go for the
people that listen see now it's and it
doesn't work of course it's not working
now they won't even go down just it
seems to be aware I it seems to be aware
it first of all you're you're not it's
like a baby okay if you start talking
about Satan you got to say him or at
least her you know I don't know what he
identifies as or what it but you don't
say it it's like a baby dude you don't
say hey did it come yet and you're like
what yeah you're baby he you mean you
can't just it's aware if you're saying
it you know it's a goddamn toaster I'm a
good lawyer
dude she's on the stand so correct me if
I'm I'm wrong you were you were saying
um
ma'am uh with the with the puffy uh
Q-tip head you you were saying that it
uh it was aware right meaning meaning
what meaning the toaster right okay but
the toaster if it's possessed it would
be who it would be Satan okay
so Satan is uh is what I don't know he's
like a he's I'm sorry he's yeah okay so
if he's in the toaster then he's the
well yeah but I and you call it it well
yeah but I I rest my case no further
questions boom got her right there
technicality oh
[__] dude the toaster went Bonkers and
[__] wow it really okay so she set it
up there's flames in the toaster that
they come up and she goes oh why does
that happen are you hearing that cut out
all right then it's my [__] she goes oh
oh why have you kept the St why have you
well
Richard I love when somebody puts
somebody's name in an answer that
they're about to give you know like if
you're like if Kristen would say Chris
why did you do that and I
said well Kristen I would already be in
trouble do you know what I mean and if
she did it to me well Chris I would know
I was in trouble either way I'm in
trouble you know but she says well
Richard I'll tell you let's see what she
says well
Richard you know when all is said and
done it makes good
[Music]
toast
dude you know how everyone's like what's
wrong with the world now we're headed to
[__]
Extinction it's been like
this you think Juno Brian's new she been
around well when all said and done you
know yeah I know it's possessed but it
makes good co good toast know it first
of all there's so many there's how many
of alls are there I think three first of
all no it does
because we saw the toast and it was
burnt to [__] all right
now second of
all I'm just going to go to third of all
because there is a second of all but
third of all is the most
crazy how
good does your toast have to
be for you to allow Satan in your
home I mean am I missing something here
toast is toast right like nobody ever
Eats toast and actually thinks well
[__] that's some good toast right toast
is pretty much you know the deal from
jump hey here's bread you want me to
toast it sure
you already know you got it locked on
it's not like a [__] sandwich it's
not like a it's not like
a a a
[__] Pizza Domino's is different than
the [__] place you're going to go
down the street I don't know what it's
going to it's toast it's [__] you
could take a match to bread it's the
same [__] thing and this
lady is like well this toast though well
this toast though that's why yes Satan's
here and it's stressful I don't know if
my whole house is going to burst into
flames like that toaster just did and I
don't know if my son and daughter are
going to live past however old they are
right now because Satan may be in them
now currently but godamn this
toast here's the second of all say
you're eating the to say it's the first
time you notice something's janky or
[__] up or ba a buub has something to do
with your [__] toaster right the
toast comes
up and you literally see it and
imprinted in the toast it's just a
middle finger just right to you or it
says Satan lives or like you know [__]
God sorry
God and you look at it and your heart is
beaten
you try
it you eat it anyway I'll tell you what
maybe but not if you're Juno
Brian and
furthermore how many times does it
happen until you're like all right well
[__] it I want toast I'm saying you
don't eat it like if I made toast and
Satan lives popped out of my [__]
thing and I don't eat it I just think
okay I'm just going to pick a new piece
of bread and then eat that but say you
made more toast and then it comes out
Satan lives Satan still lives Satan's
still living by the way by the way
Satan's still in your toaster these are
all the things that at what point are
you like all [__] it I need toast and
you eat it no you just get a new toaster
so she is lying for sure you know it
[__] yeah I'm a good lawyer boy Matson
NBC News Boer ran Florida and it
happened in Florida boy that's
odd Florida Bing janky as [__]